Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Codders. Today I'm going to talk about a product that we have
noticed great success with. It was formulated by Dr. Kelly Halnerman, who long-time business
consultant and partner of ours here at Codders Clinic. She put together this product with US enzymes,
one of the most notable enzyme companies in the world, who use all their enzymes,
called Cranzyme. Very great product. Excited to talk about it.
Euridary tract infections are a big problem. If you're a woman, especially
uridary tract infections are really common, it's common in men too, but more common in women.
Over 10 million, if you're just Google, at 10 million Dr. Pizzits a year, just due to UTIs.
And estimated nearly half of those women have a second UTI within six months of their
additional infection. The problem is that the bacteria literally abends in the bladder wall,
and it's really hard to kill. And antibiotics can work, but tend to have limited effect. If you
ever experience UTIs, you know what I'm talking about. It had elderly women, this is a major problem,
elderly men too, because they don't tend to have the same common symptoms as a younger person
with UTI. You're a younger person with UTI. You know what? You look like this woman in this picture.
You're a crappy pain. Oh my gosh, what's going on? Painful urination. I feel like you've got hit
with a wrecky ball down at your lower abdominal cavity. And elderly people that I can attest to my
mother going through this with her dementia never had any of those symptoms. Just her dementia just
escalated for a period of time. Then we knew she had a UTI. It didn't even need to test for
when he gets to that point. Elderly people tend to not get any UTI type symptoms. They just get more
worse dementia, worse anger, worse mood issues, it affects their brain more infection in the
urinary tract does affect brain inflammation. Yes, that's why they get those symptoms. Well,
crayons have is a great product because it addresses some of the struggles that you have with
trying to kill a urinary tract infection. So the crayonberry in, that's what the name of the
product here, is a huge benefit. It's got crayonberry juice in it, but also it's got PACs. PACs
when you add crayonberry extract combined with an insoluble fiber, some fiber which is the best
medical grade fiber on the market. It's used in hospitals. It limits the ability of that bacteria
in a UTI to embed itself into the bladder wall. And that is the key. So you can keep the bacteria
from embedding into the into the bladder wall. You could have better success with killing the
bacteria. So the sun fiber also acts as a prebiotic. We use sun fiber all the time as a prebiotic for
gut health, but it does so same thing with the bladder. It can be extremely beneficial. And then
the added nano kinase, which is an important enzyme to help improve probiotic status and it limits
the bacteria's ability to attach to the urinary tract. And that's again the key. So it helps break
down the mucus barrier of the bacteria and allows that crayonberry extract to help kill that bacteria
and keep health. We have women that have had UTIs just take one or two of these a day on a regular
basis. Certainly, if you're in a UTI scenario, you want to take more than that and you can
experiment with plain with dosage, but we've seen just remarkable results with the UTIs,
not just UTIs, but any urinary tract of balances. We've seen remarkable results with this. There's
really no side effects of this. It's just really fantastic product. Highly recommend it,
crayonzine from U.S. Anzine, and you can find it on our store. Thanks.